but I just finished episode four okay so
the Lannisters are the blond people and
the female lannister is married to
robert barantheon who's the king it's
zipper ran theater Baratheon right
alright and then the other blonde girl
is the can I get you something
oh I don't know um three kamikaze shots
whatever I can't believe he just did
that
what's that served me before you guys
I'm really against that I'm so sorry
that's okay
we got beers no I mean I'm sorry about
everything that's fine no no it's been a
hundred years of not fine I mean 20
years ago you guys wouldn't have even
been allowed in here 20 years that would
be 1992 it was really beautiful
oh who said she's done that just
happened didn't it yeah amazing so were
Lannisters hmm okay she's the queen
Jaime Lannister is the other one Jaime
you know what a man hey give me another
lager I mean Josh spilled my last one
I'm a tribe shirt I believe that but
whatevs got this thing in 93 Midnight
Marauders tour check that out it's
everywhere
oh hey who's your favorite member of
tribe smoke smoke
no keys no mean nothing dude I'm behind
the scenes but yeah he was like all
right good see you guys around though
mmm-hmm cool okay one more one more
come on son boom all right late always
fun
fun second-person to not wait for their
drink by the way yeah oh let me ask you
this then what what's what's with the
Barbarian dude it looks like a huge Dave
Navarro because that guy oh I need a
drink
just finished Amistad I saw it three
times and I'll see you a hundred more
times because like I'm happy to do it if
that's what those guys went through I'm
happy to sit through it you know 300
more times or whatever you know it takes
yeah it's it so it's pretty intense I'm
seeing my thing is it's like I don't
think one person should own another
person period I'm glad that that's what
you got you here yes I mean I don't care
what it happened alright it should never
happen it should never occur but it's
like I'm preaching to the choir you guys
know I'm talking about yeah like it's
like why did anybody even do that I'm
like no you did no you did what you
doing drama no you did
I'm ashamed you know what it's really
probably okay because you weren't there
okay well we can come up with excuses
all day all day let's just not do that
what's what's not look hey bottom line
mm-hmm we cool right yeah all right yeah
we're kickin a cow
yes what's it take a feeding all right
four more years
if it makes you guys feel any better
black people make me really
uncomfortable thank you
[Music]